we bring in Sam Smith Sam of course
wrote the Jordan rules about Michael
Jordan and the Chicago Bulls and it's
hopefully got a spike in new book sales
there Sam because Jordan talked about it
in the last dance and he singled out
Horace Grant one of his former teammates
as a snitch your reaction when you heard
Jordan talk about that is Horace Grant
as your snitch was what Sam yeah I think
we were talking about it with Todd the
other day not to not to celebrate myself
but that's what we do on TV right but I
had about a dozen years as investigative
reporting and doing a number of things
Bob Phil Jackson from the CBA spending
time with him Johnny Bach you know from
the early years when he was coaching up
with warriors from Brooklyn so it was a
longtime friend Tex winter I used to sit
with on the plane for years one time he
brought me I was trying to understand
the offense so he brought me the book
his original triple post offense book
that he had signed for his mother and I
said well Tex I can't have you look you
sign for your mother he said well she
died she doesn't need it and and so the
notion was well I had a wait after all
this till 1988 to a 21 year twenty-two
year old kids the world Georgia came
along saying now I can do a book on this
subject so yeah I've sort of you know
kind of laughed at it after all those
years about the you know trying to
explain when Michael says that made
people Michael said it may be wrong but
I know you're not going to give up your
sources but it was Michael correct at
all in Horace Grant being a now you
would call it a source Michael called it
a snitch you know doing that kind of I
mean you're in journalism so you know
doing that kind of project everybody's
the source yo Jackson Johnny Bach Jerry
Reinsdorf Jerry Krause even I I had
dinner on the road a couple of times as
frightening as that might sound
but Jerry Krause we were in Portland one
time I was hanging around and the I
think it was that season actually in the
in the lobby Jerry came down that change
his room seven times we
she did quite a bit he didn't like the
mattress had some issue he said hey
let's go have dinner and I couldn't
think fast enough and so but why do you
think Michaels singled out horse well I
think you because you saw this and you
know some of the reaction after the last
dance would harvest and some of the
players you know being upset you know
sort of they were there their
documentary I'm cutting in
you know harvest stood up to Michael a
lot back then and you know a lot of a
lot of the elements of the documentary
early on you know settling grudges kind
of thing Mike Michael takes names and
remember so you know Jerry Krause I say
you know in Horace Horace in an odd way
was sort of a protector for Scottie you
know early on really
yes Scottie early on they were
incredibly close and he literally would
call each other before every game that
to decide what they were wearing went
out and bought the same cars bought the
same dogs they were inseparable and and
but you know Scotty was kind of seduced
by Michaels aura and the attention with
Michael and he would gravitate over
toward Michael and then Michael you know
when you were sort of in in in his arc
there you know he didn't always we've
seen he didn't always treat you with
perhaps the respect you'd like so Scotty
would come back to Horace and complain
about you know what he said to me and
this and sort of that and so Horace
would you know would stand up to Mike
sometimes and you know when things
happen he wasn't as articulate as quick
you know it's facile and so it it didn't
come off as cleverly but you know that
they had a long history of that and and
then my and then of course Horace being
the one when he left they went to
Orlando and when the year Michael came
back in 95 it was harvest who really you
know course Shaq and Penny were the best
players but with Phil had done in that
series realizing cars not a great
shooter he doubled off Horace every time
Horace shot like 70% in the series you
know really hits the booming baskets and
then the magic players lift them on
their shoulders carry him off Horace
raising his hand you know sort of
pointing at Michael who
by the way there was no there was no
after the end of that series there was
no teammates going the I mean
players going to congratulate the other
team Michael stopped off pretty fast
after that one too
so he remembers a lot of evidence one of
when it with Horace house is playing in
Chicago this is this has been great you
know this has been obviously within a
lot of places in the country it's kept
us you know given us something look
forward to but you know for Chicago it's
been particularly special because you
know it's not it's not a city with a
great history of sports success you know
Cubs a hundred years until a World
Series 108 as it turned out you know and
and here was a celebration of when it
wasn't New York or Boston or LA Chicago
was the center of the sports world for a
decade and so for the local community
it's you know especially with the Bulls
having issues in the last you know a
couple of decades it's you know it's
been a terrific opportunity to remember
it's just sort of puff your chest out
and say hey we were number one talking
to Sam Smith he wrote the Jordan rules
co-author of Derrick Rose's
autobiography all show you which is
available in Amazon Barnes and Noble how
are the books sales for the Jordan rules
has there been a spike since the
documentary you know it's really
interesting I'm making a the same on
that as I am for this appearance the
book is out of print than they haven't
printed anymore
they haven't no they it was that was
sort of like one of those oh yeah that
would be a good idea I think I think
it's probably occurring to him right now
that maybe it'll be a good idea but I
I'm gonna looked on Amazon I couldn't
buy one like because even we'll ask him
you say well you could give me a book I
said well let me see if I good bye good
bye
oh wow so you don't pay for appearances
do you then no we don't even have you
thought about adding an extra chapter
for the Jordan rules
yeah actually just just now you know
public publishers ever since I realize
doing books they're mostly good at just
printing they're really printers a
version of Benjamin Franklin was doing
and so I think it's kind of occurred to
them now and so they just literally at
the end the documentary got back to me
and said but we're thinking of you know
maybe printing another edition of course
later this year and maybe you could
write something for it so yeah so I
probably it will end up doing that but
have it yeah also the whole flu game now
became food poisoning my after all of
these years that Michael never addressed
this or clarified it until we got to the
documentary why would he do it it wasn't
food poisoning he made that up you know
that there was you know there are
several things based on a true story
kind of thing in this and then that was
one of them I mean it you know we I know
in our society we like to believe in
conspiracies a lot because they're a lot
more fun and interesting than the truth
you know sort of like Michael being
kicked out of the NBA you know in which
they addressed quite a bit because of
the gambling and everything which
obviously wasn't the case and you know
David Stern and Brian MacIntyre and Mark
van so any number of people commented on
that people you know its associated but
he wasn't poisonous that's not what
happened and and I mean that the story
if you watch I mean you didn't watching
the documentary I mean seriously
five people Michael Jordan the most
protected nobody knows where he is
secure person all of a sudden five guys
from a pizza place and by the way who's
ordering pizza in Salt Lake City but
behind that and they were in Park City
what do you think happened to him he was
ill there's no question I think I think
he had something that wasn't as as manly
as maybe some other episodes I think I
think because what they were doing he
they were going up to Park City
in the mountains in the ski area to stay
that's where they stay so it had a
practice in Salt Lake City so they kept
coming in and out in and out and I think
it was altitude sickness the sick the
symptoms that he had fit that much more
than anything else that he had and so it
there was some sort of illness there was
no question he was ill I wouldn't deny
that he definitely was yeah he was sick
but he wasn't poisoned but I don't
understand why not just let this
sleeping dog lie that it's the flu game
we've yeah we celebrated this ain't now
all of a sudden even when he says it's
Sam in the documentary he doesn't say it
in a convincing manner that he had food
poisoning he looks away he says it and
he looks at what like hey I got a I got
to believe this it was food poisoning
and I'm thinking you were you got away
with this it was the flu now all of a
sudden it might be throw in a Cuban
cigar to some drinks and altitude
sickness and you got a guy who looks
gray when he walks into the building
that night well people always said said
hangover and stuff and to me that was
sorta irrelevant cuz Michael never slept
got up and played golf you know two to
three hours of sleep you know if he
drank smoked cigars that that was you
know thirteen years of stuff and he
still went out and got fifty so that had
nothing to do with it
yeah right there was no there was a
reason to yeah there was also you know I
part of it was it was I think the you
didn't need to add drama to this
documentary it was a great show
otherwise the Jordan story well it was
like you know they had the beginning and
you know the theme of 82 and I Oh Jerry
Krause you're never coming back you know
and that's it so you got to end the
documentary also in a similar way he let
he didn't want to play that next year he
he could have in any number of ways so
he said it made that up too at the end
that I wish I could have come back I
wanted to come back he didn't he didn't
want to come back you know I mean it was
a look it was a whole team there other
than Scotty who you know was limited by
the time the end of the finals had have
surgery again you know went to Houston
had a poor season Durant you know left
and there went the Portland he was just
a role player so then you know that
Kukoc Harper winning ten
Brad there were numbers simply there was
a number of team there and they had
money for free agent and they actually
had it Brent berry that season it was a
good free agent you know so if he wanted
to stay and Rodman of course was coming
back for the one year it was begging him
for that one-year deal and so if he
wanted that one year and the 40 million
he could have gotten it and and he just
didn't want to play I mean we saw it
would with a mod and all those scenes
that hey I've had enough you know I'm
out of here you know I got a move on you
know so I mean but it was a better story
to end it that way to say hey you know
yeah one more chance going for seven I
should have done you know we could have
done that no I didn't want to do that
but you know the other thing too about
that is we always complain about all
these athletes Unitas and Willie Mays
and Ricky Henderson whatever why did
they do why why didn't they just quit on
top we did he quit on top we should we
should be celebrating that he left us
wanting more and then he came back to
the Wizards well we don't count oh we
don't and wasn't in the documentary
therefore doesn't exist that one was I
was the GM as your memories the Jim of
the Wizards he had supposedly part
ownership and my part of Michael is look
if he if he could he would come back and
play now because some of these guys in
the document challenged him and said he
couldn't through it Brian Russell didn't
get interviewed probably said I could
take him now and he would come back and
play again if he could and he would try
you don't know that that that's who the
guy is he was always about the game more
than anything yeah
had the famous love of the game clause
in his first contract you know he really
wasn't about the advertising in the
marketing and you saw his mom wanted it
made him go after you gotta go see Nike
he just wanted to play and so you know
that's it that's his nature the guy so
he couldn't help himself when he went
with the Wizards because he's looking
around at all these guys and you know
he's beating them and he says I could
beat you all in practice so he's
he's played them all in practice and
beaten them play I mean that was a that
was just a wonderful part about the guy
who just never could stop him he just
wanted to play games all the time Sam
thanks for joining us we appreciate it
and you know good luck with the Derrick
Rose book and thank you for sharing
these stories at Sam Smith the Jordan
rolls and they all show you a biography
autobiography Derrick Rose and Sam Smith
available now at triumph books com
Amazon Barnes and Noble and through your
local independent bookstores